Dwight Howard oh that's cold so I'm just
looking at the birthdays I'm just
looking at the birthdays of all these
guys everybody born to the mid late 90s
and here you come as an eighties boy I
used to always talk about great Oh
taking hours to get ready for the game
now I'm doing it tell me though the way
this overall just you know that time
I've watched you in high school so she's
like 16 that's a long time and then to
see you now just overall being before we
get to the dunk contest it's a tribute
to how long you still playing you in
great shape yes sir so I'll talk about
how your career now is still extended
just just to play this game I think
that's the best things got my legs back
got my mind right my body and just be
the best way out and the way you've been
phenomenal this year and we applaud you
for your play and obviously here in slam
dunk contest you talk about spirit just
a team you guys have you seem like
there's a real genuine spirit together
Ness it's really kind of fun to watch
just talk about that man I love my
teammates man we really enjoy each other
you know no matter if it's on the plane
the bus the court practice we just love
being around each other and it's a great
feeling to have when everybody was like
man we got one goal one this is the best
championship and we don't get there
together what about your role coming off
the bench
oh you adjusted to that it does about
you know wherever they need whatever
they need me to do they needed
clean the bathrooms whatever whatever it
needs to be done you know I'll do it you
know just for this team is that an
approach you think you could have
allowed yourself to have in Prior stints
in the NBA or is the song yeah no doubt
I just think this is just the best
opportunity and I mean could you have
had that mindset whether it be in
Charlotte Atlanta Washington Houston LA
the first time or is this because you're
older and mature and you're able to have
perspective now as opposed to when you
were younger
ah no I would do it I've always just
wanted to win a championship or whatever
it takes to win you know I think no one
you younger you know sometimes you plan
for different things and stuff like that
but as you get older you know what
matters you know you take you don't take
anything for granted and every moment
counts no matter no matter if you're on
the court for five minutes ten minutes
you want to make every single minute
that you have on the floor you want to
give everything you got because you
never know when it's gonna be your last
it wasn't just the years of me going
through heartaches and stuff like that
it was more so the injuries of being
away from the game you know so when I
got back on the court it was like all
the other stuff doesn't matter mom play
this game and get my body at myself
everything I got every moment because I
don't want to look back and say I wish I
would've did it to you
now look at it really fast for it now
the dunk contest 11 years ago you want
it and now I know you can't give us
what's going on but tell me how you feel
far as your legs and jumping goes with
during the regular season about you you
bouncing man I feel amazing I can't wait
to fly tonight
okay we give something away Chicago I
can't wait - tonight I'm looking forward
to tonight man just to have a smile on
my face and be out there in front of all
the fans just enjoy this atmosphere and
this is something that you can never
give back and with the situation that
happened with Kobe just just kind of
like kind of woke me up people more like
man you gotta enjoy everyone dunk
contest last summer and I'ma win the
dunk contest whenever both participate
in you weren't on yet
I wasn't on the team yet I was in the
gym working out and I said I'll do the
dog contest I'm already so so bad but
when you've made that determination was
it because I haven't done in a while I'm
feeling healthy I felt great okay so I
felt great and I went to the gym and I
did it dunk and everyone's like dude
that was like I'm gonna do that at duck
huntin you mentioned you mentioned Kobe
and we're obviously we're honoring him
all weekend long and remembering him
what was the plan if Kobe I can't say
because I'm still gonna do some of it
tonight but but Kobe was going to be
part of it with me will you explain a
little bit of what the kind of thinking
was and what you guys are talking say
that I can't say it because if I do is
on good way to hold up you know so I
just would say that he was supposed to
be a part of tonight so I'm just gonna
do my best and honoring him and you know
I really appreciate him you know that's
something that uh I really wish I would
have had the opportunity to tell him
before he passes you know how much I
appreciated our time together how much I
appreciated just the knowledge that he
was trying to you know give me
you know at a young age is hard to hear
what somebody's older telling you at the
time you just had two different levels
and that's what communication is it's
very keyed I don't I think we didn't
communicate when we wore the same teen
and I just can't get those moment back
those moments back stuff just for
anybody out there man whatever issues
that you may have with anybody whatever
just let it go let it go you talk about
playing with Kobe Bryant years ago but
now you playing with LeBron James player
former foe you guys had great battles
back in the day but just talk about what
it's like playing with him and the
second half of the season what do you
guys need to do to win that championship
well I enjoy playing with a bird you
know we've been opponents we've been
battling since we were in high school
and now we have an opportunity to win
together just being around I'm like man
we have this same type personality you
wanna have fun you want to get everybody
involved you don't want to leave nobody
behind and we want to win and for the
second half of the season it's time to
bear down just on the bear down lock in
and dominate every single night you know
we don't want to wait til the playoffs
are trying to turn it on you want to
start now and I think everybody on our
team we have that same mindset they're
gonna enjoy ourselves for all-star
weekend and then it's time to get the
word who's your biggest threat tonight
of the 14 field in the slam dunk contest
myself you know but I just I just really
believe that when you focus on other
things and other people at what they're
doing and tend to lose focus on what you
got to accomplish and tonight I know
what my purpose is
you white I'm fired up for it many
peoples of [ __ ]
[Music]